hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to well
Christmas is over Santa has come and I
guess I got a little bit of the
post-christmas blues I mean 12 months
waiting weeks upon weeks of hoping for
the world's greatest Christmas gifts and
what did I get a Nintendo B
entertainment system - fully functional
controllers the latest edition of Super
Smash Brothers Brawl and no Mario Kart
suck my candy canes Santa that was the
cream of the Yuletide crop and you can
do it instead what did I get my stocking
a holly jolly dose of bullshit known as
jingle all the way the first and thank
God only Christmas film 2 star
international punchline Arnold
Schwarzenegger and since I got the
post-christmas blues you're gonna share
this hunk of stinking yellow snow with
me so grab your vomit bags and get ready
to find out oh what fun it is to ride in
a horse ships viewing fuck ride like
this one let's take a look so it starts
out with a show called turbo man I'd say
it's like Power Rangers for younger kids
but it's more like Power Rangers for
retarded kids I mean I think this is the
film's first big hole no normal
functioning kid would actually watch
this intergalactic space craft I mean
seriously what can we'll watch a show
with a flying hunchback Sabretooth Care
Bear in it well apparently this kid
would a little boy named Jim played by
Jake Lloyd Jake Lloyd hmm where do I
know that man
my god what a tall building he's upset
because his father is a workaholic
played by Arnold Schwarzenegger I just
be upset my father saw its maker the
last draws one Arnold misses his son's
karate graduation
I know tries to make it but it's caught
in traffic has also stopped at the
world's oldest policeman look sir
I'm in kind of a hurry hello if you're
in a hurry Arnold tries to her up but
ultimately misses the ceremony I didn't
make it
thanks Arnold I never will figure that
out if you didn't say something where's
this movies for the blind I'm walking
down the hallway I start to catch my
breath I look into an empty room with a
janitor to emphasize what the douchebag
I am I didn't make it
things don't get much better when it's
next door neighbor played by Phil
Hartman starts becoming more fatherly
than he does sorry you missed the karate
class today but don't worry I got it all
on video for you hi I'm Troy McClure you
may remember me from such horrible
Christmas classic says here comes Steven
Seagal frosty the man damn and the
Stallone who stole Christmas
Arnott tries to apologize to his son
that Jamie's heart has been broken too
many times for Andalus Jamie don't walk
away from your father you will come to
me Jamie or I would destroy you blah is
this it wow this is really cool what do
you think Jamie yeah yeah and this guy
was a multi-million dollar action star
life is stupid but I know still feeling
bad tries to find a way to make it up to
his son if there's something really
important you've been wanting for
Christmas well I've always wanted to
ruin a Star Wars movie
I'll have the turbo man action figure
with the arms and legs that move and the
boomerang sir
the rocket roars epic you'll shoot your
eye out kid Jionni's gonna get one so is
everybody else I know whoever doesn't
can be a real loser well it definitely
won't be you thanks dad I love you O
materialism brings everybody together
that's what Christmas is all about
there's only one problem though Arnold
doesn't have the doll
which reminds me you got the doll right
the doll I love how the wife isn't even
really acting here she's just preparing
for the world's most unconvincing head
duck for the camera he does it so fast
or she hits her head on the sink
you got the doll right that's gonna hurt
I also love this over-the-top expression
that Arnold gives that looks like the
cliffhanger of a horrible 80 sitcom
because at this point they'd probably be
impossible to find uh-oh
how's Arnold gonna get out of this one
billion time to get the gift or will the
most unpractical and unpossible of high
jinks ensue
did you forget next time when
masterpiece' ship theater continues we
find out though that while arnold has to
get the doll he might miss the Christmas
parade that they always go to but Arnold
reassures his son apatheia I promise am
I the only one that thinks this touching
moment looks relatively threatening
apatheia or I will eat you Jimmy ah I'm
waiting in line at the toy store he
comes across a mailman who's looking for
the same toy played by the thankfully
underappreciated Sinbad faithful fans of
dollars on TV advertisement and then I
sit there and use subliminal messages to
your children wise up if you were
somehow blessed with not remembering
this early 90s rape of comedy consider
that your own personal Christmas gift oh
okay he's not that bad but he does seem
to have this unique talent of just
sucking the comedy out of a senior even
if there's no comedy to be found and
then they sit there making kids feel
like garbage that you the father who's
working 24/7 deliver mail
you make an alimony payment to a woman
that's not with everybody at the post
office but me you hear that lack of joy
and laughter that most people hear when
certain comedians are around fat it's
the power of sin that they try to go and
get the doll but it turns out the store
is all out I'm trying to find a
gentleman doc these guys are looking for
a turtle man
ajahn Chah woman don't leave the
hottest-selling Christmas toy ever and
don't think I'm having a psychotic
episode where's your Christmas spirit
that's the owner we all know and love
now watch their head like grapefruit
fuzzy he spots someone driving away with
it but unfortunately the driver
recognizes Schwarzenegger and correctly
steps on the gas
Arnold goes from store to store trying
to find the turbo man but comes out
empty and he takes his frustration out
on a cardboard cutout as it's the only
performance that's more wooden than it I
will destroy you come on yeah as if we
didn't have enough annoying performances
Bill Harmon comes in again to put the
moves on Arnold's wife it's Christmas
Eve and you're slaving over a hot stove
is this the mom of the year or why it's
no big deal and modest too
you know I'm the antagonist in this
picture because I'll totally written in
tag it is always talking to slimy
over-the-top boy things get even worse
when Arnold tries to call his wife and
instead gets nasty make Jack ass on the
line Ted I need to speak to my wife I
think she's in the shower
Howard want me to go check no you stay
away from my wife what meet you your
wife's cookies are out of this world who
told you you can eat my cookies will
stay away from my cookies oh these
cookies I gotta get the recipe from
lives but then cook it down stay away
from my wife stay away from my cookies
and stay away from my wife's cookies why
destroy yo there's a next batch gotta go
Howard
give er
oh hey look all it is oh good for a
second there I started tolerating the
art of filmmaking you and I we're the
same kind of first thing yeah except
he's successful and you're not well it's
like delivering a turbo man toy work at
the store unfortunately they hand out
colored balls that will take place in a
drawing that will decide who gets the
toy who doesn't trouble man who's
faithful pet tiger booster and stock fun
full stop give me the tub imagine
turning on things get ugly when the mob
breaks out in sympathy eels the ball
away from our big dog hey he's try him
just bite him that eaten unfortunately
the ball moves a lot like flubber as it
keeps getting higher and higher than
more times it bounces around it falls
into the hands of a Shi and early
undefinable child as Arnold roams
through the malls playground to get it
back out of my way children want you to
I need you on yeah hi little girl girl
that's what
because fortunately more people
recognize Arnold and give him the proper
greeting that he's used which still
means no turbo man but Hulk comes in the
shape of a Belushi you want a turbo man
for Christmas forget it I'm not gonna
sit the new lap that's not my bag hey a
gay joke in a Children's Zone Merry
Christmas he tells him where he can get
a turbo man at this sort of underground
disgruntled Santa workshop where they
sell hard-to-find toys at outrageous
prices but Arnold has given a false
product as he tries to escape the
workshop without paying but this is
harder than seems as Arnold's confronted
by dozens of Santa's killer elves and
even a ninja that uses candy canes as
nunchucks ladies and gentlemen welcome
to idiot land where nothing is too
ridiculous or too insulting to anyone's
intelligence want to see Arnold fight
homicidal Santa Claus is with a candy
cane nothing is too hard for us an idiot
land want to see a muscle-bound giant
hit a little person across the room in
the realms of idiot laughs anything is
possible
idiot land it's full of so Arnold
finally escapes and calls his son to
live though the bad news that not only
did he not get the doll but he probably
won't be able to make it to the parade
when someone makes a promise they
definitely should keep it you know it's
like what turtleman says always keep
your promises if you want to keep your
friends yeah ding what would you know
about keeping your promises you never
keep your promises you never do anything
you second don't ever just pumpers mine
what damn you Howard gee that wasn't
home dramatic damn you Howard damn you
damn you hello my pizza is gonna be late
damn you because the pits of hell
decided we haven't suffered enough we
get another appearance bison man as he
tries to patch things up with Arnold
once more I'm having one Christmas I
want this one special toy Johnny seven
OMA gun
remember those don't you know
remember the commercial like it was just
a date G would you be so kind as to not
free enacted for us dying to Peter
Johnny Peter enemy sighted
Roger there Oh Johnny we wanna be seven
OMA one-man-army gun seven days ago
things looked like a blast
damn you are wondering how much he's
getting paid for this movie Arnold
suddenly looks over and imagines his son
having a very similar future here's to
you dad your God my son is going to
broth Amin unsuccessfully unfunny black
man but the chase continues as they rush
into a radio station that apparently
gives out the turbo man to anyone who
can answer a holiday question but that
turns out to be bogus too so the police
come in thank God to try and take them
away
but Cindy tries to get out of it by
taking one of his packages and
pretending it's a bomb
chappie you shouldn't mess with that
gentleman you've been duped just as
people huh
that's not your kind of funny huh this
movie actually had a fine hominid
smiling actually smiling really funny
how many years in the bomb squad no no
you're ruining the joke don't ruin the
one honey see you have in this movie did
you actually get it you were the only
funny joke in the movie you jingle balls
of ass damn you damn you all Oh Arnold
Stewart's to the ultimate low as he
tries to steal a turbo man from phil
heartman house but luckily a psychotic
blood hungry reindeer huntin down to
make sure he doesn't get away with hey
don't look at me I didn't write his wife
finally decides to take her son to the
parade leaving Arnold behind Ted would
you drive us of course
you can't benchpress your way out of
this one
Arnold searches for the appropriate
response fuck you asshole
huh it turns out the reindeer is still
hungry for Austrian meat oh good what do
you think the big witty Schwarzenegger
line is gonna be you started it
oh what's that that's all you got come
on you're Arnold Schwarzenegger you're a
professional at this come on there's a
million better witty lines you could say
like normal reindeer games or hasta la
vista Rudolph or if you're really
desperate I'll be buck just show us that
you're trying so they show up to the
parade of the only affordable copyright
characters dick again where Arnold tries
one more time to set things right here
he's mistaken for a stuntman slash actor
isn't he already where he slipped into
here's a big shocker
a terrible man outfit I guess it figures
Arnold already resembles an inanimate
object that shouts nothing but corny
catchphrases I know you your boost oh
yeah and who the hell do you think you
want Mary Poppins
whoo that's an image Arnold
Schwarzenegger as Mary Poppins Oh
deleted
Arnold also partakes in get this a
special part of parade where he hands
out a turbo man doll to special child in
the audience gee I wonder who it could
be Jamie
he knows my name and he has a thick
Austrian accent for some reason so Jamie
marches up there and collects his prized
and has the greatest Christmas Day ever
all right hello routine yeah I'm gonna
say something like all that wasn't as
bad as I thought would be good I mean it
was bad but wasn't horrible
and then the movies got a surprise me
with the shittiest part of the entire
film well I'm not gonna fall for him
no I'm betting you anything that this is
not the end of the movie merry Christmas
to you know not be in not being wise I
think turtleman is selected a winner
really no surprises or anything no
last-minute climax no cheesy
over-the-top special effects really okay
all right I mean it's true it wasn't as
bad as I thought would be any it was bad
but not nearly as horrible is it's turbo
man's archenemy
fuck you mommy fucking fucking fucking
fucking fucking fucking so Sinbad comes
in dressed up as turbo man's
arch-nemesis the green dildo you've
taken this too far yes listen to the
person dressed up as turbo man he's not
taking anything too far so the boy runs
away with the doll and Sinbad tries to
get it from everybody just applause as
they assume this is all just part of the
Act this could be the end of
civilization as we know it
no argument here so don't do now kid
that's my Jamie kick him in the balls
they are man's greatest design flaw so
Jamie actually climbs up a tall building
all because he can't give away his
beloved fucking turbo man all right kid
dang to the line just check this out
never
I will shoulder joint and burn with my
commercial piece of plastic okay kid
there's liking to toy and then there's
insanely obsessing over on toy I mean
your life isn't worth it just give him
the damn plushie a little moron by the
way does anyone notice that this is the
longest docked parade stud in the
history of the implausibility well the
rate this parade is going santur should
float by in roughly 12 hours use your
jetpack
it's
so let me get this straight a parade
that can barely afford what looks like
two balloons and only a few copyrighted
characters can afford a only functional
rocket pack that even NASA couldn't
perfect yet is there a name for what's
wrong with these writers so he's flying
through the city and hey alright ladies
and gentlemen the film just gave up it
clearly doesn't care about the story
narrative or making any semblance of
logical sense so they just said fuck it
and start showing images that will
hopefully entertain your kids well you
know if they say you can't beat them
oh it looks like Jamie is slipping
German German no I would have no one to
eat my late haha so of course on the
rescues the boy and saves the day thanks
to the
you are much better than that other
overbuilt Austrian guy that I look up to
oh thank you sir I don't think you know
how much he means to me oh I think I
have an idea I was a dad could have been
here you know see me flying all but he
didn't come your dad is not mad at you I
do you know all that yes
don't tell strange muscle-bound big
t-square town Austrian accent is he mate
wasn't in any way my father huh who
would know better than me Wow
I haven't been rich doc since I found
out the secret to living a long lasting
life what screaming oh wait what's
little Jamie up to Merry Christmas
Wow just gonna make my son really happy
soon as I'm done serving 5 20 hey I'm
sorry about that a little tension we had
on roof up there hey it's cool I don't
care that you tried to savagely kill me
just to get your hands on a children's
possession to satisfy your own sense of
self-worth for me that's what Christmas
is all about but Jamie I thought you
wanted this goal more than anything what
do I need the doll for I got the real
turbo man at home
a turtle man who neglects me it puts his
work before anything else
so long Jimmy and off to neglect you
some more wow I can safely say that
we've all learned absolutely nothing
well they do one thing check out all the
way can jiggle all the way to hell this
is the worst Christmas gift since Donald
Trump's toupee it goes against
everything that Christmas is about gets
soaked up in a festering ball of
commercialism and actually has the balls
to somehow get Otto Schwartz and Edgar
and Sinbad in there so Santa for giving
me such a good gift this year I'm just
one thing to say to you you better watch
out you better not cry you better not
pout I'm telling you why but it sounds a
critic is coming to your home bitch I'm
rip roarin cast I remember it so
yo-ho-ho